you were saying how you know previously
in your music used to say the n word
yeah for people who don't know
what is your racial makeup i'm puerto
rican and i'm irish um
my father who was irish passed away when
i was four okay i'm saying i've been
around but
i'm i'm in new york that's that's how
just people talk in general like even
the white guy said the asian people
right you know when you grow up around
in new york there's no neighborhoods
there's just one race mm-hmm you live
next door to a very very different next
door to somebody from pakistan and your
next neighbors from from
the age from from from china your next
door other neighbor might be dominican
right right right right right it's like
a melting pot you know what i'm saying
and and and growing up
it was never even known that it was a
racial thing that just became part of
our vernacular how we speak to each
other um and just growing up
it was never a problem until i started
doing tours and going to other cities
besides new york and then i would see
people how they would react to me saying
it because
when you look at me you might see
different people see different things
people see me seeing puerto ricans some
people see me some people think i'm
russian some people think oh yeah yeah
some people think i'm i'm i'm arab i'm
totally like yo if you told me you were
like you know if i came here
yeah armenian or something yeah like yep
absolutely so depends on what you see
but if you look at me and see i'm white
then you would have a problem saying it
and and
you know i'm not gonna go and and tell
everybody yo i'm from the heart i'm not
nah it's just if you don't like it say
something nobody never said nothing to
me a person but as a man and just what
i don't want to give people a shot of
not liking me before they even hear me
and more importantly than that
i don't want to make any i'm out of
asian and i'm growing up and being
become more mature with myself that i
don't want to
say anything to somebody that's going to
offend them
you know you don't have to when i don't
have to like why start off like
how when i grew up i was had to be tough
and all that but as i grow up man i'd
rather laugh with you than joke with you
i rather talk about our similarities
than our differences and and just the
climate that the world is at right now i
just was like yo i'm cutting this off
out of my music in my last album congo
is that your first album where you guys
that's my first album where
i didn't use the word because i'm i'm
maturing as a man but also as an artist
and um
that just is there's no for me
personally i don't have to say it i'm
i'm i have a a a vocabulary where i
don't have to say it right i'm saying i
could i could kill verses and kill bars
without having that in my music and like
boom it's done that's though man yeah